right over here
[Music]
great there he is
[Music]
oh
i heard
[Music]
yes
and by the way
his mother
who can
i don't know your password
ready
hey
all right
uh
yes
you guys make around please
just gone up here
go for a second please guys
we're gonna move to the other end
really come on seriously dude
sir
even worse dude
they said yeah with him
we got nothing come on hey guys
okay guys let's move back let's push
back you guys come hook back please
thank you push back
flag right here
push back all day long
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
okay bit
more
thank you
told us we were going to get beer
rick areas
[Music]
is
[Applause]
i just want to know
absolutely
oh
ready
[Music]
well
where's the area
is
dude
well the
it looks like
okay
[Music]
okay
is
is
tomorrow
um
i'm sorry
[Music]
oh
who has the time to sit here at the
airport for hours
while we left these
is
[Music]
[Music]
what's that
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
wow
hey guys
you